I am firmly convinced that in the future
the majority of urban transportation
will take place in the air it's
something that we as society have wanted
for over a hundred years
little kids grow up drawing pictures of
flying cars building them out of Lego
and dream of having their own one day
record the flying cars because it's our
aspiration we really want to change the
world the flight it might start with
your Amazon and Google package delivery
but it's going to go to people we're
already seeing it happen with
self-driving cars we already seeing it
happen with little drones these
different kinds of technologies are
enabling new kinds of transportation we
are going to cover drone technology a
variety levels we're going to spend some
time talking obviously about the higher
level autonomy and the mission planning
really what this course is about is
giving students the chance to implement
algorithms and ideas and technical
concepts on aircraft what we want to do
is we're gonna try and make that future
happen sooner by training future
engineers and the technologies needed to
make that vision happen Udacity is a
great starting point for anybody who
wants to learn more about these
technologies more about this application
domain and more about flying vehicles
this is something that no one talks
about but I promise in a few years time
to run the hottest topic on the planet
so come to the skies with us by applying
this world's first flying car
none of the we've program
you